bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france je n'étais pas là je
jour des caricatures c'est ce qu'a
finalement confié la collégienne
pourquoi at elle finalement décidé de
reconnaître son mensonge
écoutez elle a été prise dans un
engrenage qui l'a totalement dépassé et
elle et s'est sentie prise par un poids
qui était beaucoup trop lourd à porter
pour elle et du cou lorsqu'elle était
entendu par les agents de la dgm si elle
a reconnu les faits c'est à dire
qu'elles n'étaient pas présentes le jour
de la diffusion de ces caricatures
oui c'est ça c'est un aveu qui est
consécutif à sa mise en examen pour
dénonciation calomnieuse le 25 novembre
dernier absolue sans cela est ce qu elle
serait revenue sur ses propos est-ce
qu'elle aurait compris la gravité de ces
accusations
écoutez évidemment qu'elle aurait
compris parce qu'il ya quand même une
situation assez tragique avec le décès
de monsieur paty et ma cliente n'a
jamais souhaité la mort de son
professeur
donc oui elle a pris conscience très
vite très tôt de la portée de ses dires
est ce qui l'a poussé à proférer ses
accusations envers samuel pâtit alors
qu'elle n'était pas présente à ce cours
écoutez comme je l'aï dit à plusieurs
reprises il ya un contexte assez
particulier concernant ces caricatures
qui ont été assez mal perçue par
certains camarades elle a eu le
sentiment qu'elle devait porter la
parole de ceux et celles qui avaient été
gênées par la diffusion de ces images
après pour le détail de ses motivations
qui l'ont poussé à tenir pareils propos
l'ex on expliquera un jour et prendra le
temps de donner les motivations qui
étaient les siennes à l'époque que
va-t-il se passer pour elle puisque on
imagine dell va devoir répondre de ce
mensonge devant la justice écoutez
l'infraction en tant que tel des
dénonciations calomnieuses à les
caractériser
puisque rien il ya un mensonge
il n'y a pas de mystère sur sa
culpabilité maintenant ce sera la
sanction qui lui sera infligée
et c'est là que je vais intervenir pour
pour minimiser la sanction qui sera la
sienne
et pour faire en sorte qu'on prenne en
considération le contexte ce fameux
contexte qu'on a tendance à oublier
qu'on a tendance à gommer pour céder le
pas à la facilité à la caricature
donc mon rôle en tant que conseil c'est
de le présenter ma cliente dans un
contexte particulier dans une séquence
avec des effets des éléments qui la
dépasse et qui l'ont amené à être pris
dans ce tourbillon que vous comptez
faire en fait c'est expliqué dans ce
contexte vous nous parliez il ya
quelques instants le fait qu'elle se
soit vu comme le porte parole de ses
camarades auprès des enquêteurs
oui c'est à dire que l à certains de ses
camarades qui l'ont demandé de rapporter
un malaise par rapport à la diffusion de
ces caricatures
après ses camarades ont pas tous hein
parce que ce n'était pas non plus envoyé
par tous les camarades de sa classe mais
certains compter sur elle et elle a eu 7
7 cette mission elle s'est sentie porté
par 7 7 7 ce mandat pour justement
développer ce point de vue qui était un
point de vue mensonges et comment se
sentent elles aujourd'hui étant donné
l'issue tragique que l'on connaît pour
samuel pâtit quel est son sentiment
aujourd'hui comment se sont-elles
écoutez c'est ça un tourbillon
tourbillon émotionnel
vous savez là comme je les dis à la 13
ans messieurs patty est mort et ça le
regrette
son père était incarcérée elle a
conscience qu'elle a que là qu'elle a
menti qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû mentir
tout ça a pris une proportion incroyable
une proportion tragique
il faut pas oublier une chose aussi
c'est que elle ne connaît pas
l'assaillant elle ne le connaissait pas
jamais tu en contact avec lui ne sais
même pas à quoi il ressemble c'est pas
quelqu'un qu'elle qu'elle fréquente ni
de loin ni de près et ça c'est important
de le dire parce que on laisse entendre
par moments qu'elle était en lien avec
le bourreau de monsieur patine on fait
bien la distinction entre le mensonge de
cette collégienne est l'acte terroriste
qu'a commis sept assaillants vous pensez
que beaucoup de personnes encore
aujourd'hui au contraire font se lire là
pour et que ça nuit à votre votre
cliente que ça peut lui tenir encore
devant la justice évidemment évidemment
c'est pour ça que lorsque j'étais
j'étais sortie du bureau du juge
d'instruction antiterroriste
avec ma cliente je n'avais fait aucune
déclaration j'étais intervenu dans aucun
média et ça c'était le 25 novembre
on est aujourd'hui en mars et cette
volonté de ma part d'être silencieux
c'était justement pourrait les laisser
cette affaire retomber un peu pour
éviter l'emballement médiatique et là il
s'avère qu'il ya une fuite
récemment qui s'est produit dans le
dossier que le parisien puisse se
procurer des éléments des procès verbaux
du dossier qui très volumineux et du
coup moi je suis je suis je suis
contraint de sortir du bois pour éviter
toute confusion toute caricature et tout
raccourci fâcheux à l'endroit de ma
cliente voilà elle a menti c'est une
réalité elle n'aurait pas dû à le
regrette amèrement
mais jamais elle n'a encouragé souhaiter
la mort de monsieur pâtit j'amène a
appelé à son massacre et la décapitation
et ça c'est important de le marteler que
l'opinion publique prennent conscience
que cette fille de 13 ans est
responsable de son mensonge mais n'est
pas coupable de la mort de deux sapeurs
pompiers merci beaucoup mais qu tabou la
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct sur rt franc je rappelle que vous
êtes l'avocat de cette connectique qui
avait donc accusés avaient menti au
sujet de leur ciel samuel pâtit merci à
vous